nous avons dans le studio yves clément
président du modem pour parler notamment
du modem dans ces départemental yves
clément une esquisse de réponse
oui une esquisse de réponse bonsoir
d'abord une esquisse de réponse sur le
plan européen puisque c'est l'une de mes
thématiques favorites il ya en ce moment
de plus lancé depuis quelques semaines
un projet d'initiative citoyenne
européenne qui va dans le sens de ce que
vous dites en ce moment pour obliger un
certain nombre d'eux
d'entreprises ou de conglomérat à des
cas a déclaré plus et mieux alors je
veux pas rentrer dans l'est dans les
détails de manière à ce qu effectivement
tous ces paradis fiscaux soient
progressivement
neutraliser et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que c'est une initiative citoyenne
européenne se dire que chacun de
l'ensemble des citoyens de l'union peut
la signer et s'il ya suffisamment de
signatures ça oblige la commission
européenne à se saisir du sujet et à
faire une proposition qui passe après ou
non devant le parlement qu'il faut
vraiment attendre une pétition pour agir
non mais c'est bien que l'ensemble des
citoyens seraient mais je pense gauche
grande partie des citoyens sont
conscients de ce problème après c est ce
que les hommes politiques ou facétieuse
et les élus comme on les appelle ne
devra pas aussi prendre leurs
responsabilités et agir pour le peuple
par le peuple la
cible est bien sûr bien sûr votre
élection c'était donc le 9 décembre
dernier
oui voilà début décembre en tout cas on
avait suivi ici
les péripéties quelques adhérents du
modem nous avions même eu ou par
téléphone monsieur lefebvre l'ancien
président bernard lefebvre l'ancien
président du modem et voilà on se disait
c'est un parti qui
le centre à orléans ça ça veut dire
quelque chose mais le modem en lui-même
voilà c'est un petit parti ces centres
du centre c'est le centre du centre mais
on se demandait pourquoi il y avait
autant de bisbee autour de cette
présidence les discussions ont été vives
non
oui
d'abord peut-être pour rappeler que je
fus le président du modem jusqu'en 2004
au moment où j'ai démissionné vie et
puis là je suis donc à nouveau à nouveau
président ben oui comme dans mes
mouvements je vous rappel man toutes les
associations au moment où il ya des
élections mais il ya des gens qui se
présentent heureusement j'avais dire
c'est démocratique bien sûr ville à
douala ensuite l'élection se fait et il
y en a une qui est oui non mais enfin
moi je me rappelle pourquoi vous aviez
démissionner l'époque en 2005 mais les
auditeurs peut-être pas alors rappelé
j'avais démissionné en 2004 juste juste
avant l'élection des élections
régionales
parce que j'ai eu une divergence
importante avec
le siège national de mouvements sur les
têtes de liste ici en région et j'ai
considéré que
appartient où ils avaient fait un choix
et moi en tant que président local
président départemental je ne pouvais
pas rester président et emmener les
troupes au combat puisque j'étais pas
d'accord avec le choix qui avait été
fait 1-1 politique ça ferme sa gueule ou
ça démissionne ouais bah tu vois
c'est que j'avais ouvert ma gueule puis
démissionner d'abord alors le
promener au à la tête de ce parti avec
pas mal de problèmes également le modem
pour aux dernières municipales notamment
à orléans s'est singulièrement scindé en
deux ou même trois certains partent en
avant avec le maire sortant de l'époque
est réélu serge grouard d'autres partons
avec la candidate socialiste corinne
leveleux teixeira et d'autre part tu en
arrives avec tarbes et ahmed zabana de
preuves indépendantes
vous avez quelle position l'époque vous
à moi je n'étais pas concerné je ne suis
pas au relais à mais si c'est vrai vous
êtes l'iftar c'est vrai et pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas même vous n'êtes pas allé aux
municipales à olivet vous parce que j'ai
considéré que j'ai déjà été élu ainsi
été adjoint au maire d'olive et j'ai été
conseiller général il y avait une époque
de 2,2 me l'implication politique à
travers ses mandats après j'ai fait
autre chose y compris des engagements
militants syndicaux et européens voilà
il ya des moments pour des choses
différentes dans la vie mais alors le
modem enfin globalement en français on
dit que
l'udps et ikki à l'autre partie du
centre maintenance iphone vos troupes ou
c'est quoi la réalité c'est vrai
peut-être un tout petit peu d'histoire
oui allez le modem il est né en 2007 je
suis pas très bon sur les dates quand je
dis on fait faire de l'histoire de ça
commence mal le modem il est né en 2007
ou 2008 bref
par transformation de ce qui était à
l'époque
l'ancien udf et l'udf s'est transformé
un certain nombre de gens ont rejoints
et il ya eu cette création du modem
impulsée par françois bâillon oui allez
y oui et bien et puis donc tout ça a
vécu avec la grande la grande époque de
la présidentielle de bayod qui avait
fait 19 ours
et puis ensuite il ya eu un certain
nombre d'eux deux ténors du modem qui
eux n'ont pas ont pas voulu forcément
quitter le modem mais qui ont voulu
quitter françois bayrou qui ont divergé
par rapport à françois et donc qui ont
créé le nouveau centre
puis ensuite il ya eu un certain nombre
de
d'agglomération j'allais dire de
différents partis le nouveau centre le
parti radical et c'est au sein de l'ue
dit sous l'impulsion de borloo voilà
comment tout ça c'est créer hors jeu
passif il ya vraiment des le mot a un
sens politique ou pas entre le mode eco
d'éluder ynwa eux
j'en sens
relativement peu sur toutes les
questions de fond les questions de
société les questions d'europe les
questions de fiscalité
voilà je sens relativement peu de
différence c'est pour ça que à titre
personnel je pense qu'à un moment ou un
autre
il faudra à nouveau être capables de
travailler ensemble c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui avait impulsé ya un peu plus d'un an
borloo et bayrou lors ce qu'ils ont
lorsqu'ils se sont rencontrés et qui les
ont mis en avant ce mouvement qui s'est
appelée l'alternative qui est allé
ensemble aux élections européennes la
différence est peut-être aussi alliance
ou pas avec l'ump qui est le principal
parti de droite si on exclut le front
national probablement parce que si on
entend les ténors de lui dit il dise
notre partenaire naturel c'est l'ump en
ce qui concerne le modem
nous ne sommes pas aussi eu
n'être que ça nous voulons en ce qui
nous concerne rassembler des gens de
sensibilités différentes qui veulent
transformer qui veulent rénover la
politique ils peuvent être à l'ump mais
ils peuvent être aussi au ps ou être
nulle part disent un peu notre différend
a mais disons nous la vérité il faisait
bon si c'est si c'est peut-être une
question contre ou pour ou contre
nicolas sarkozy 6 alain juppé qui est
candidat de l'ump aux élections vu les
relations qu'il avait que françois
bayrou dont le modem ira vers l'ump
alors ça c'est tout à fait probable mais
je crois pas qu'on puisse eux réduire en
tout cas moi je veux pas qu'on réduise
les mouvements politiques ou les idées
politiques à des questions d'hommes
malheureusement ce sera fait mais c'est
malheureusement ce qui se fait souvent
en politique dans tous les partis
d'ailleurs c'est passionnant la cave ni
en parler du front national le front
national c'est marine le pen et avant
c'était jean marie le pen le modem c'est
bayrou est d'ailleurs
il ya une très grande différence chez le
citoyen e lambda j'allais dire c'est à
dire nous tous entre eux la perception
du modem et la perception de françois
bayrou avait beaucoup plus de gens en
france qui connaissent apprécient eux
soutiennent les idées de françois bayrou
que celles du modem et pourtant françois
bayrou et le président du modem donc ça
pose aussi des questions à l'intérieur
de notre mouvement politique qui lui
aussi doit se ce évolué allez allez de
l'avant chercher d'autres solutions oui
on a commencé cet entretien à paraître
le nationalement va continuer à peu le
front national alors le point de vue du
modem 6 au front national c'est n'ont
jamais non bon y'a même pas discuter
d'un possible effet ça c'est ma question
je sais même pas si à la question la
plus posée un jour par contre partie
république a ou non alors aussi pour le
front national est-ce qu'il faut un
front républicain systématiquement pour
les prochaines élections non par la
police que vous considérez le art
national qu un parti républicain ou non
c'est aussi une des grandes questions
qui enfin cette question euh je sais pas
répond à cette question le front
national eux ils existent ça n'est pas
un parti interdit voilà il a un certain
nombre d'élus donc sur ce plan là on
peut considérer que c'est un parti entre
guillemets république mais les idées
qu'il véhicule sont pour moi des idées
qui ne sont pas républicaine qui sont
anti républicaine et c'est pour ça que
je le combats je combat pas la personne
de marine le pen ou de je ne sais pas
qui je combat les idées mais le front
national qui risque d'être en tête en
tout cas au premier tour au prochaine
dans de très nombreux candidats doit
absolument et pas forcément que dans
notre département ben c'est ça vous fait
quoi mais ça me fais quoi ça me fait
penser que
nous tous collectivement dans les
mouvements politiques et nous et nos
élus particulièrement on ne sait pas on
n'a pas su
écouter entendre et apporter des bonne
solution parce que tout le monde dit ça
maintenant aujourd'hui c'est une réalité
mais voilà une fois qu'on a dit le front
national va être en tête au premier tour
ce qui probablement vrai
ça reste du constat du cancer reste du
constat bon alors je crois qu'il faut
retourner
au contact de monsieur et madame tout le
monde pourquoi est ce que madame
machin qui habite dans la commune du fin
fond de la beauce où il ya 350 habitants
est allé voter front national
et les travailleurs concernés par le
chômage enfin je dis c'est ce sont les
questions qui fonctionne
il faut aller discuter avec jean l'air
dire pourquoi vous votez front national
vous avez peur de quoi quelles solutions
vous a pas apporté
va vous répondre moi je sais quand je
sers puisque j'ai posé la question à
certains dans sa lettre que je veux dire
il ya beaucoup d'immigrés mais pas dans
ma ville mais à côté à 10 km et va vous
dire que n'a pas de travail parce que le
fiston n'a pas de travail vous avez des
réponses à ça je pense que les réponses
il faut justement les trouver
collectivement en se mettant tous
ensemble c'est ça la cetm enfin pour
revenir un peu sur le front républicain
qui évoquait julien je sais pas si c'est
la bonne définition pour moi en tout cas
mais je pense que on ne fonde
transformera ce pays qui complètement
embué on parle sur le plan politique
nous on pourrait parler sur le plan
syndical ou associatif ou militants
d'une manière générale il n'y a plus
personne dans les associations il ya
plus de militants il ya plus de
bénévoles il ya plus voilà
si on veut
comment dire
ouvrir tout ça et redonner confiance aux
gens il faut aller discuter avec eux il
faut se mettre tous ensemble pour
travailler cc c'est bien une bonne
difficultés parce que par définition le
parti politique quel qu'il soit son
intérêt c'est d'être le plus fort tout
seul
les cantonales on en parle maintenant le
modem n'abandonnez pas retombée
départementale pardon oui c'est vrai
qu'il ya tout tout change c'est tout
semble reste des collections absolument
et le conseil général et des clés
conseillers départementaux seront élus
devient 20 conseils département puis
parce que ça finit en fin 2015 ya plus
de conseil départemental hier un mail à
web mais c'est conseil général louis à
paris dès cette élection là enfin dès
l'élection du futur président ça va
s'appeler conseil départemental
ceci dit c'est peut-être du détail mais
c'est peut-être plus lisible même que ça
s'appelle conseil départemental plutôt
conseil général oui bourrelets et
l'existence de département pour vous ça
a du sens il ya eu il ya cette
discussion là sur sept ce débat sur les
feuilles territorial chez
j'ai depuis longtemps je suis partisan y
compris quand j'étais conseiller général
oui va de l'art de fusion
des conseils généraux avec les conseils
régionaux parce que je pense que les
mêmes élus s'étaient pas une question
d'économie parce que l'économie elle est
absolument un film sur les indemnités
des élus mais je pense que ça avait du
sens que les mêmes élus de terrain
puissent gérer les compétences des
départements et des régions en même
temps ça aurait donné certainement ça
aurait fait quelques économies ça aurait
donné du sens à la politique et ça
aurait permis certainement de mieux
gérer ou ça permettrait de mieux gérer
un certain nombre de choses
objectivement aujourd'hui que les
départements s'occupe des collèges que
les régions s'occupent des lycées je
vois pas bien la différence entre en
termes de personnel qu'en terme de
bâtiments en termes de transport de
salles de sport c'est la même chose donc
il y aurait une seule collectivité
locale quels changements en termes de
transport l'ailer laird
de comment dire l'air l'air d'un lycée
beaucoup plus grande colère d'un collège
sur les transports c'est induites des
transports plus long ils sont plus
d'internât dans des lycées même des
choses à différentes les
on voit pas après l'aménagement du
territoire forcément de la même façon
quand on a amené des lycéens pour un
lycée ou des collégiens pour info un
collège oui mais les les transports ne
sont pas je pas trop entre détails mais
ne sont pas à la charge
des collectivités locales face off par
exemple le transport des oui les
collégiens handicapés pour les pour les
conseils généraux mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que
le conseil général d'à côté le conseil
régional de l'autre son boulot c'est de
construire des bâtiments de les
entretenir
et et de et de gérer l'aspect matériel
administratif restauration etc pour moi
je vois pas de différence entre un
collège et un lycée sauf la taille bien
sûr et je pense que et les élus des deux
collectivités et les personnels
administratifs seraient capables de
faire ça et je vois pas pourquoi à un
moment ou un autre on dirait pas c'est
par exemple la région qui gère tout ça
alors le modem ne présente pas des
candidats partout dans tout dans tout
l'est dans tous les cantons dans le
loiret où et dans le loiret
département je sais pas en fait
non on en était venu aux valeurs olwen
en mai dans le loiret
on va donc avoir
ce que je voudrais dire d'abord c'est
que on est dans une élection
complètement délirante complètement
kafkaïenne
juste pour redire c'est pas qu'une
question non un c'est pas simplement
parce que le conseil général devient
conseil départemental il y avait eu 41
cantons qui ont été redécoupée il y en a
plus que 21 donc on est plus sur les
mêmes territoires géographiques ok
première premier changement et deuxième
changement changement du mode d'élection
avec non plus eu un ou une candidate
avec ou d'une suppléante mais un binôme
qui se présente avec un binôme suppléant
donc c'est difficile de comparer ou de
ou de regarder par rapport au passé le
seul point positif de ça de mon point de
vue c'est que le binôme va forcément
entraîner la parité dans l'assemblée
conseil général on a déjà maintenant la
parité dans les conseils municipaux dans
les conseils régionaux on l'avait pas
dans les conseils généraux et en
particulier au conseil général du loiret
où il ya très peu de conseillère
générale par rapport aux conseillers
généraux donc ça ça va être une bonne
chose la parité va être enfin une
réalité maintenant pour revenir sur la
présence du modem dans cette élection on
n'y a réfléchi alors d'abord eux
objectivement c'est pas la peine de
raconter des histoires on était nous en
novembre et décembre pris par nos
élections internes donc on n'a pas
vraiment
hull temps on va dire ça comme ça de
préparer l'élection au conseil
départemental
c'est comme ça c'est un état de fait
deuxièmement je fais partie des gens qui
pensent et le conseil départemental
était d'accord avec moi que c'est pas la
peine d'aller présenter du monde pour
présenter du monde je veux dire quand on
se présente à une élection c'est parce
que hein on a envie d'y aller 1 et 2 on
a le l'appétence les compétences voilà
quand on n'a pas eu des gens qui ont
suffisamment d'envié ou qui sont
suffisamment prêt c'est pas la peine
d'aller mettre du monde pour mettre du
monde je pense que ça sert vraiment à
rien donc en fait que nous avons fait
c'est que nous sommes présents sur trois
des 21 cantons
l'un des cantons qui se trouve kiki et
la fusion des deux anciens canton d'amis
et châlette sur loing mon à un jeune
garçon qui s'appelle cyril fort qui est
candidat comme titulaire et nous sommes
présents dans deux des cantons d'orléans
je vous dirai pas les numéros des
content parce que je suis pas encore au
point là dessus enfin grosso modo nous
avons sur deux des cantons d'orléans
dans un canton une femme martine arsac
dans l'autre un homme valmy nomi qui
sont le rang 10 suppléants en fait la
loi dira remplaçant voilà ça veut dire
quoi c'est que le modem ne prendra pas
de position politique pour ces élections
où vous vous allez soutenir parce qu'on
va vous demander à un moment ou à un
autre forme et si vous allez vous
soutenez tel ou tel candidat telle ou
telle politique vous souhaitez mener
d'autres partis politiques sur d'autres
pandas ou sur la sur la ville dans l'ain
en tant que tel sur les quatre cantons
d'orléans content que telle la position
qui a été prise a été de soutenir la
majorité municipale en place puisque
nous sommes entre guillemets aux
affaires avec la municipalité en place
il ya quand même une certaine logique
pour les élections départementales à
avoir la même attitude et le même
positionnement de marsac et monsieur
nomi sont donc conseillers municipaux
même adjoint je crois à la valise aux
conseillers municipaux de la ville
d'orléans valmy et ans et 30 adjoint oui
d'accord freiner puis sur le canton
chalet t'habilles notre candidat cyril
fort est un jeune homme qui est adhérent
du modem qui s'était présenté aux
élections municipales de châlette sur
loing je crois et qui part en binôme
avec une dame classé au centre pendant
classé à droite au centre droit je ne
suis plus une dernière question sur le
modem
consciemment encore ces cantonales je
sais qu'il ya eu ce débat là lors de
votes de l'élection qui vous a porté à
la tête du modem le certains soutenaient
l'idée que le ça n'avait pas de sens
d'avoir un modem 45 donc un modem du
loiret mais modem régional oui ça c'est
c'est pas tout à fait comme ça que ça
s'est posée mais nous avons j'avais déjà
proposé il ya
sept huit ans je crois avec jacqueline
gourault sénatrice ces matrices modèle
du loir et cher j'avais proposé que
progressivement on aille vers une
régionalisation notre mouvement
politique parce que je pense moi que ce
avec quoi comme avantage mais je pense
que la vie politique et on commence à le
voir là elle et elle va progressivement
être articulée autour
j'allais dire au niveau de base la
commune et son intercommunalité la
région qui est qui va structurer le
territoire on parlait tout à l'heure de
deux structures les transports raison
c'est l'algérie de la pression qui gère
par dans les infrastructures qui gère
les fonds européens maintenant donc pour
moi la région c'est vraiment le la
collectivité locale d'avenir entre
guillemets et on avait considéré qu' un
mouvement politique en l'occurrence le
modem se devait de se caler sur ce qu'il
souhaitait que soit l'avenir des
collectivités territoriales et donc il
ya eu un référendum interne au sein des
six départements de la région centre des
adhérents modèle ce référendum a donné
un résultat positif donc on s'en va vers
une régionalisation du modem dans les
deux ans qui viennent afin faire donc
voilà ça va se faire ça ça c'est déjà
fait je crois dans deux autres régions
de france mais je voudrais pas dire des
bêtises en particulier je crois l'alsace
d'accord on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler sur cette antenne si vous
voulez voir dans un restaurant nous
allons parler de l'europe parce que
pendant longtemps vous avez eu des
fonctions
européenne oui j'en ai toujours ah c'est
vrai oui je suis toujours fan je suis
maintenant une vice présidente nationale
du mouvement européen france france vous
en était le président je t'ai le
président du loiret et le loir et et je
viens de passer la main parce que j'ai
considéré que ça ne serait pas sain
d'être à la fois président du modem qui
est un parti politique et président du
mouvement européen qui est un mouvement
trans politiques aillent un mot j'allais
oublier parce que on m'a envoyé cette
question là
avant notre le début de notre entretien
sur le cumul des mandats
est ce qu'il y a des problème de cumul
chez vous il ya certains chez vous qui
s'émeuvent du fait que vous vous
présenter des candidats qui vont cumuler
je ne sais pas oui donc il s'agit de
ceux d'orléans forcément alors il s'agit
des deux d'orléans dondon jeu dont j'ai
bien dit qu'ils étaient suppléant voilà
c'est pour ça que c'est c'est un set un
cumul qui n'en est pas vraiment un quand
même voilà mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
éviter le cumul des mandats et que la
dernière loi qui avait été adoptée qui
interdit maintenant d'avoir deux
fonctions exécutives en même temps par
exemple comment dire et l'intéressé à
l'europe de même très influent j'allais
dire un président président ancien
président du mouvement pour l'europe du
loiret d'orléans ou du loiret
bah oui on va envoyer les tout de suite
en l'europe ccc quoi l'europe
ben on voulait faire la focus sur ce qui
s'est passé avec la grèce
voilà un gouvernement de gauche radicale
qui est élu par le peuple est largement
qui arrivent et qui bute dans le
feuilleton sur le fait de remplir c'est
ce qu'il a proposé au peuple parce que
l'europe sinon c'est ça l'europe
mais d'abord ce gouvernement il est
élu de manière démocratique
donc il faut évidemment que les 27
autres
membres de l'union européenne respecte
le choix qui a été fait par le peuple
uraca c'est la première chose
d'autant plus que je voudrais qu'elle
rappelait que la grèce c'est laid et les
retraités le berceau de la démocratie
mais elle n'est redevenu démocratie
qu'après une période très douloureuse
très difficile qu est ce qu on appelle
régime des colonels entre 67 et 74 la
dictature des colonels et donc bon voilà
il ya eu un vote qui apportait alexis
tsipras ce
à la tête du gouvernement après juste
dire que pour ceux qui ont suivi les
dernières élections au parlement
européen
il y avait cette année une nouveauté
c'est que il y avait un fléchage pour
savoir qui serait le futur président de
la commission c'est aujourd'hui jean
claude juncker et dans les candidats à
la présidence de la commission il y
avait alexis tsipras ce et je sais pas
si vous vous souviendrez de ça mais dans
les tables on qu'il a fait avec les
autres d'ailleurs
alexis tsipras ça a été relativement
brillant et il avait eu une position en
tant que candidat à la présidence de la
commission qui était une position très
pro-européenne
c'est pas parce que la grèce est dans
des difficultés importantes qui sont
d'ailleurs en partie dû aux décisions de
l'union européenne je vais y revenir que
il faut dire que le peuple grec et
contre l'europe ou et antieuropéen le
peuple grec il est
il l'est dans l'union européenne
mais aujourd'hui il souffre de décisions
qui ont été prises parce qu'elles ont
été prises de manière trop forte trop
radigue par l'europe par l'union par
l'union européenne mais s'est refusé de
remplacer que vous défendez il c'est
cette europe là que je défends parce que
c'est aussi à chacun des pays membres de
faire son boulot chez lui j'ai pas si on
reviendra sur la situation en france
mais puisqu'on parle de la grèce si la
grèce est dans la situation
qu'elle a connues avant 2007
c'est parce que au moment de son entrée
dans la zone euro et un certain nombre
de choses qui n'ont pas été faites la
grèce est rentrée dans l'union
européenne en 1980
en 2001 elle est rentrée dans la zone
euro et pour entrer dans la zone euro
tout candidat à la zone euro doit
respecter un certain nombre de critères
e.on est maintenant très nombreux à dire
que les critères de l'époque
bon je sais pas s'il y en a qui ont
fermé les yeux ou qui était aveugle ou
que ça arrangeait tout le monde toujours
est il que en 2001 la grèce ne
remplissait pas ne remplissait
probablement pas je suis quand même
prendre cette précaution notamment les
critères de maastricht les critères pour
rentrer dans la zone la zone europe
aujourd'hui elle est dans la zone euro
et la zone euro est une zone de
solidarité
et
je suis en désaccord total
avec l'expression de l'ancien président
valéry giscard d'estaing qui dit il
faudrait que la grèce sorte de la zone
il a fait si la grèce sort de la zone
euro ça n'aura un impact que très faible
pour les pour l'union européenne et pour
l' pour la zone euro elle-même mais pour
le peuple grec
ça sera absolument terrible parce que ça
veut dire que ça bête elle va augmenter
de manière
no mé nal parce que évidemment la
monnaie ne voudra plus rien donc ce
qu'il faut probablement faire c'est
trouver
un certain compromis je pense que c'est
ce qui est en train de se faire entre
les engagements qui ont été pris par les
dirigeants grecs jusqu'à présent parce
que des engagements pris par des
dirigeants les autres les dirigeants qui
viennent en place doivent les tenir
c'est vrai comment en france c'est
vraiment mal beiträge mais il faut
permettre au peuple grec de retrouver sa
fierté et sa dignité et il est
il est juste de dire que ce qui était
imposé au peuple grec parce qu'on a
appelé la troïka eu fmi
la banque européenne et
l'union
ont été trop dur trop fort mais en même
personne ne l'a dit à l'époque aucun des
vingt aucun des pays membres de par
exemple en est la confédération
européenne des syndicats à laquelle un
homme une femme ou à laquelle je siège
l'a dit de manière assez fort bon ben
alors vous avez vous débarquez à la
basse et toujours le problème des dvd
des groupes de pression c'est à dire
qu'à un moment dit des choses en écoute
et en lait - etc mais ce que je veux
dire aussi c'est que les dirigeants
grecs doivent faire un certain nombre de
réformes comme le dirigent mais ils ne
disent pas le contraire on a vérifié il
me semble qu'ils ne disent pas le
montrer à vous ont des comptes quand
même que non je crois qu'il dise pas le
contraire maintenant reste à savoir
s'ils vont pouvoir le faire parce que
dans la campagne alexis tsipras ce a
développé un certain nombre de positions
d'idées dès lors des idées simples oui à
donner la retraite aux gens éviter que
les gens meurent au coeur au coin de la
rue je veux dire c'est le mot c'est le
minimum et personne à l'europe yves
clément encore une fois que vous
défendez personne a eu l'impression de
la fin tout tout le monde lui dit non
j'ai l'impression non non c'est pas ça
c'est moi je crois que si j'ai bien
compris cette ses positions à alexis
tsipras ce elles sont je vais dire juste
elles sont légitimes
mais dans le même temps il faut que les
réformes
qui traîne depuis des années en grèce se
fasse par exemple
il y à un certain nombre de lois qui
permettent à certaines grandes fortunes
notamment les armateurs de ne pas payer
l'impôt
deuxième chose l'homme l'église
orthodoxe grecque qui n'est pas qu'une
église mais qui est aussi propriétaire
de nombreuses activités de nombreuses
bâtiment qui a des fonds importants etc
etc il ya une
une réglementation spécifique qui fait
que l est elle aussi elle échappe un
certain nombre d'imposition il n'y a pas
en grèce de cadastre ce qui fait qu'il
peut pas y avoir d'impôt foncier puisque
personne ne sait à qui appartient quoi
et que surtout il faut pas y toucher
toutes ces réformes structurelles qui
n'ont pas été faites et je pense à un
certain nombre de choses qu'on pourrait
faire en france d'ailleurs en disant ça
toutes ces réformes structurelles qui
n'ont pas été faites elles doivent être
faites et si elles sont faites
il y aura effectivement
là les rentrées financières suffisantes
pour que à la fois la grèce rembourse
ses emprunts mais aussi pour que le
peuple grec puisse avoir des revenus
décents une retraite décente une
sécurité sociale ce qui n'est pas le cas
en ce moment et ce qui est absolument
anormal
julien mais non en fait on devrait
arrêter aussi de peut-être de de
dialoguer ou d'essayer de faire des
désaccords avec le fmi parce que c'est
ce type d'institutions qui favorise tout
le contraire de ce que vous venez de
dire je viens travers à travers le monde
le fmi a depuis déjà des 10 des dizaines
et des dizaines d'années
imposé de ce genre de pratique ultra
libérale qui ont à chaque fois amené des
pays acp dans le chaos enfin alors je
veux je connais pas suffisamment le fmi
pour me prononcer sur les actions du fmi
e par exemple en afrique ou en amérique
du sud mais en ce qui concerne eux
l'europe en tout cas enfin dans l'union
européenne
moi je fais partie des gens qui pensent
que l'union européenne est suffisamment
intelligente structuré avec des moyens
etc etc pour être en capacité de ne pas
dépendre du fmi de se passer du fmi et
de travailler sans le fmi veut dire
aujourd'hui le l'économie de l'union
européenne est suffisamment charpenté
suffisamment bâti pour pouvoir
comment dire
et dicter ses propres règles internes et
et mettre en place cette solidarité
d'ailleurs l'union européenne au départ
c'est une idée de solidarité c'est pour
qu'ils n'aient pour qu'il ne qu'il n'y
ait plus à nouveau de guerre pour qu'il
y ait la paix et la croissance comme ça
que quelques aînés l'union européenne
donc il faut que l'union européenne se
dote d'outils financiers elle a commencé
à le faire et pas suffisant pour
progressivement être en capacité de ne
pas par exemple dépendre du fmi mais
enfin le fmi faisait partie la troïka
quand même absolument et non seulement
en grèce mais avant au portugal et
l'espagne aussi non ils ont ils sont pas
intéressants voilà
mais bon c'est de fait mais voyez eux
vous venez de parler de l'espagne et du
portugal
quinon qui ont des régimes politiques
différents de celui de la grèce et donc
comme ça ça permet de d'élargir le
propos c'est pas une histoire de couleur
politique la grèce et l'espagne eux
aussi ont eu recours au fmi entre autres
il ya une union européenne pour sortir
de la situation dans laquelle ils
étaient l'espagne et le portugal n'ont
d'ailleurs pas eu les mêmes les mêmes
attitudes interne mais aujourd'hui ils
sont sortis du chaos j'allais dire en
particulier le peuple portugais a fait
beaucoup beaucoup d'efforts ak mairie
oui en acceptant en acceptant d'aider
mesures ultra libérales notamment en
acceptant des mesures ultra libérale
mais en ne passant pas
ce qui existait or aujourd'hui en grèce
l'aide européenne
elle est arrivée et les dirigeants grecs
ceux d'avant tsipras ce n'ont pas mis en
place un certain nombre de réformes qui
auraient permis de rendre plus saines
l'économie de faire payer l'impôt à ce
qu'ils veuillent pas par exemple le dire
c'est un vrai scandale en grèce ma peau
c'est un vrai scandale et pourtant le
dire l'ancien gouvernement dirigé par
des conservateurs
avait l'appui l'aval de la majorité des
pays européens même si c'est ça ne rien
comprendre pourquoi ils voient la mairie
mais je crois que on va revenir à ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure de faire de
la politique et être eux en situation
de direction c'est à dire être élu c'est
faire des choix et faire des choix c'est
aussi ensuite les mettre en application
depuis des années depuis des décennies
les dirigeants grecs quel qu'il soit
gilles bien quel qu'il soit parce qu'il
y ait différentes couleurs qui sont
succédé n'ont jamais eu pris les
décisions permettant d'avoir un cadastre
de faire payer l'impôt à ceux qui le
payent pas etc etc et donc on est dans
une situation terrible vous parliez des
riches des armateurs depuis l'arrivée de
syriza au pouvoir il ya une beaucoup de
deux fonds qui sont partis oui des pays
européens ont accueilli des fonds de
très riches armateurs ont fait quoi fin
je pense que je pense au luxembourg
notamment je pense à brno mais on fait
quoi dans ce cas là on est heureux on
est à l'europe on ferme les yeux parce
que c'est c'est c'est pour ça alors
qu'on dit qu'on veut aider les animaux
cie et type race alors on fait quoi mais
je pense que c'est pour ça qu'il faut
aller plus loin
comme on est un certain nombre à le dire
dans une sorte deux
entre guillemets gouvernement économique
de l'union européenne parce que
aujourd'hui
la manière dont l'impôt est conçu est
perçu dans chacun des pays de l'union il
est différent et il faut faire un
travail de
rapprochement
ce travail de rapprochement il doit
commencer par définir
qu'est-ce qui est imposable c'est pas la
même chose aujourd'hui dans tous les
pays de l'union avoir une base commune
j'entends beaucoup parler tout comme un
c'est vrai que le taux de l'impôt sur
les sociétés il est très important en
france les très faibles en irlande etc
mais c'est pas le tour qui compte c'est
la base au départ donc il faut faire ce
travail là et ensuite pour revenir sur
l'histoire de deux entre guillemets de
l'évasion fiscale ou d'évasion des fonds
c'est que il faut mettre plus deux
moyens sur les cellules des changes de
données financières et comptables c'est
enfin on dit ça depuis des années et
rien fait rien ne se fait il ya des
parts qui se font l'union européenne et
se construit pas à pas mais il faut
aller beaucoup plus vite dans ce dans
cette direction là je n'ai pas retenu
les chiffres mais c'est eux hier ou ce
matin les chiffres qui ont été cité par
le commissaire européen en charge de ça
si on arrivait à
faire payer aux taux le plus bas actuels
de l'union européenne les fonds qui
s'échappe on réduit ray on retrouverait
je crois un demi point de croissance
c'est monstrueux vous est fantastique
alors que pensez vous de cette
expression jeu que j'adore d'un collègue
de la presse économique qui dit l'union
européenne en paraphrasant une citation
célèbre d'un commentateur de foot
l'union européenne c'est une partie qui
se joue à 28 ou à la fin c'est toujours
l'allemagne qui gagne
et est ce que ça vous fera ça comme non
ça me va pas parce que
il peut pas y avoir faim dans une union
européenne
quelques mois je la conçois il peut pas
y avoir de gagnants et de perdants
mais de fait c'est l'allemagne qui fait
la loi sur la grèce en tout cas ça on a
beaucoup entendu l'allemagne notamment
l'humaniser finances jean bleu alors
seul hier aux jo landes c'est un peu tu
d autres encore plus ouais mais c'est
pas si on peut dire ça comme un homme
bon
l'union européenne elle enfin c'est
comme dans une famille vous avez 28
enfants ou petits-enfants tout ça c'est
la même famille mais chacun est
différent
et tout ça ça doit vivre ensemble
travailler ensemble il y en a qui sont
des mecs qui a fait plus d'études de
finance l'autre café plus l'autre qui
est plus culturelle à l'exception
culturelle française par exemple c'est
vrai que l'allemagne veut imposer un
certain nombre de choses sur le plan
financier la france dit dans un autre
domaine mois l'exception culturelle
française c'est vachement important et
je veux pas qu'on y touche et nous
français on trouve que c'est très bien
de dire ça les allemands il trouve
peut-être que c'est très bien ce que dit
chambre donc il faut aussi
qu'on n'est cette démarche de l'esprit
qui est pas très facile je dis que moi
même elle m'est difficile parfois c'est
de dire
je me mets à la place de l'autre pour
essayer de voir comment il a vécu de
comprendre ce qu'il a vécu et ça va ça
va m'aider à aller de l'avant a par
exemple eu nos amis européens qui
viennent des pays de l'ex europe de
l'est
ils ont pas vécu la même chose que nous
ici à l'ouest et quand on leur parle de
deux fonds européens pour reconstruire
un frac par exemple qu'on a fait à
orléans parfois ils se disent mais vous
marchez pas un peu sur la tête de mettre
de l'argent européen pour construire un
bâtiment culturel on a tellement de
besoins nous pour notre agriculture est
finalement les deux positions elles sont
vraies ça dépend de quel côté on se
place donc il faut que cette union
européenne elle elle marche elle se
donne des objectifs
elle marche de l'avant et elles
permettent à ceux qui sont les plus en
bas entre guillemets de progressivement
rejoindre la moyenne
c'est le cas du smic européen par
exemple pour voir n'y arrive pas et
pourquoi n'y arrivera pas je pense qu'on
va y arriver ouais y'a des images
expliquez nous donc et betteraves et par
l'est de l'allemagne et pour parler de
l'allemagne
l'an dernier une grande très grande
décision a été prise par l'allemagne
elle n'avait pas de smic l'allemagne
très bizarre elle vient de dellal décidé
l'an dernier de mettre en place un smic
alors ça va se faire progressivement sur
deux ans mais mais il va y avoir un smic
en allemagne qui va voir le jour et ça
c'est bien mais aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que c'est la réalité du smic c'est en
bulgarie
je suis allée n'ya pas longtemps le smic
enfin l'équivalent du smic il est grosso
modo à 150 euros au luxembourg
l'équivalent du smic avait une paire
grosso modo attend une grosse taille
grosso modo à 1200 euros au luxembourg m
bon ben c'est sûr que l'on va pas du
jour au lendemain eux passer 150 à 1900
mais en même temps le coût de la vie en
bulgarie il balles non plus le coût de
la vie au luxembourg donc il faut
relativiser tout ça et mettre tout ça en
perspective
yves clément merci d'être passé m'a déjà
fini c'est déjà fini c'était bien
intéressant mais vous reviendrez
certainement un pur et je vois qui a
écrit ici il est interdit de boire fumer
et manger donc on a discuté c'est ça
nous avons discuté en tout cas merci de
votre partie aventure en plus vous
revenez travail